what is
[Music]
moving away from its RPG roots the
original of the city of Final Fantasy
traded turn-based battles for real-time
action duels featuring an all-star cast
from the franchise it told an original
story that celebrated the series's
diverse incarnations while also
presenting an odd yet satisfying
approach to character action but in
aiming for a more competitive focus
along with some half-hearted offerings
for solo content the newest installment
Dissidia Final Fantasy NT from Square
Enix and team ninja loses sight of what
makes the Final Fantasy series so
memorable resulting in a hollow journey
through a franchise's storied history
squall wait what is it is it another
summon when the war in God's materia and
spiritists call forth the heroes and
villains to engage in a new fight for
the fate of their collective universes
the Warriors soon realized that there is
a greater threat lurking in the
background
forcing rivals to set aside their
differences to take on the encroaching
menace much like its predecessors
Dissidia NT is very much a celebration
of the Final Fantasy mythos set across
different locales from this series is
past including Final Fantasy once
Cornelia and sevens Midgar several the
stages recreate the same style and tone
found from their respective titles along
with the return of iconic musical themes
and other references to past titles
including the appearance of the tutorial
mukou who continues to overstay his
welcome the brawler pays great attention
to creating a mash-up of the most iconic
elements from 30 years worth of
noteworthy games Dissidia NT story
campaign makes attempts to justify the
backdrop of its chaotic slugfest while
offering some room for fanservice taking
control of several heroes from the Final
Fantasy series they'll fight against
their own rivals and corrupted copies of
other characters as they come to grips
with the reality of their present battle
well the many cutscenes throughout are
charming the story as a whole feels
undercooked even disregarding some of
the newcomers to the roster this is made
worse by some rather odd choices and how
you go about experiencing the narrative
story progression uses a node-based
system with cutscenes and key battles
costing memoria to unlock you'll often
have to grind experience in the games
other modes earn more tokens for the
campaign this ultimately makes the
campaign a fragmented experience you
can't go through at your own pace
weakening the impact of the story's more
meaningful encounters often building up
dramatic fights that you've already
experienced several times over how did I
know you would be here to switch things
up during the story your party will
engage in boss battles against several
of the game's summoned monsters but
while the scale of these fights are
impressive and the game's visual luster
shines throughout these battles also
present massive difficulty spikes in the
campaign given that they're capable of
wiping out your party in single moves
with ease these large battles feel more
like clumsy exercises and trial and
error rather than a culmination of your
skill with a roster of well over twenty
characters including familiar faces such
as the brooding loner types Cloud Strife
& squall Leonhart along with newcomers
ramza and noctus from Final Fantasy
Tactics and Final Fantasy 15
respectively there's an impressive set
of brawlers to choose from each with
their own unique play styles
the city is action will force you into
split-second decisions to make sure your
hits count by building up attack power
with non-lethal brave attacks draining
your opponent's power in the process
you'll be able to deal greater amounts
of raw damage to your opponents with
lethal HP attacks
moreover collecting energy from randomly
placed crystals will allow your team to
call in your chosen summon monster
turning the flow of battle in your favor
battles are set in large arenas so
you'll constantly be on the move
utilizing defensive maneuvers along with
support spells and buffs to stay one
step ahead of your rivals combat is
mostly kept on a relentless pace and
when you're in the thick of it the
fighting system allows players to
exhibit some rather clever strategies
rewarding those who can read their foes
next move while the system may come off
as a bit overwhelming for newcomers the
generous tutorial mode will put you
through your paces to learn all the
necessary mechanics to survive
[Music]
the three-on-three format makes for more
hectic battles and while these are fun
to take part in for most of the times
they often result in overly busy
encounters with all fighters bunching up
made slightly worse by an overstuffed
user interface the camera also struggles
to keep up with the action which is
especially frustrating on the higher
difficulties er during online play as
you clear through battles increase your
player rank and character level require
Gil for use in the item shop while you
can buy cosmetics and collectibles in
game you can also find treasure packages
yielding a set of randomized rewards the
rest assured you can acquire every item
on your own as there are no real money
microtransactions in the game whatsoever
[Music]
the city antes online experience is a
big focus for the game including ranked
matches along with custom games tuned to
your own preferences you'll be up
against skilled players who are looking
to boost the rep online unfortunately
simply waiting to take part in online
battles can be a chore during the first
week of the game's release online
matchmaking took upwards to 3 to 5
minutes to get a game going moreover
several the matches were burdened with
sudden lag spikes and skipping resulting
in some rather uneven encounters what's
most disappointing is that in going and
headstrong into its competitive
multiplayer angle Dissidia NT doesn't
offer much outside of it if the online
multiplayer and repeat excursions into
the gauntlet boat don't interest you in
the long term then you may find yourself
with few reasons to proceed with the
games already repetitive offerings for
all its attempts to honor Square Enix's
long-running series the city of Final
Fantasy NT stumbles far too often when
trying to replicate the heart of the
series it's paying tribute to while that
manages to offer fun and responsive
combat along with an infectious charm
throughout it struggles to advance much
from the previous Dissidia titles with
the story that sped piecemeal behind
arbitrary gating several combat
encounters that feel out of place and
unreliable online systems that don't
function when you need them to this
online brawler is enabled to live up to
the series as steadfastly tries to
celebrate
[Music]
please make it interesting
you